así es fue por unanimidad de los 10
ministros presentes que la corte declaró
inconstitucional un artículo del código
penal del estado de coahuila que
penaliza el aborto sin embargo a pesar
de que solamente se trató del código de
coahuila esto sienta una jurisprudencia
y es de aplicación general en todo el
país de manera que a partir de ahora si
un juez tiene en sus manos un caso de
aborto tendrá que ceñirse al criterio
fijado este día por la suprema corte y
declarar inconstitucional cualquier
criminalización del aborto ya en algunos
estados en los códigos penales
despenalizan el aborto es el caso de
ciudad de méxico veracruz hidalgo y
oaxaca
sin embargo dejaron los ministros en
esta discusión la tipificación de aborto
como delito pero éste ya no podrá ser
criminalizado